bitte bitte bitte seit wann ist ein
salzgitter hallo sauer
ja und zwar jetzt sagt sauer salzig ja
leute was geht ab jetzt willkommen zu
einem neuen video ich habe weder mein
bruder dabei und zwar zuerst mal eine
frage wir haben uns überlegt wir machen
eventuell bald zusammen channel und so
hat neben war ich mache natürlich den
ihr als haupt channel weiter aber
unterhalb mit ihm weil er wollte eben
mal mit youtube so ein bisschen anfang
und ich ihm gesagt ja komm mach es
einfach zusammen wenn ihr bock drauf
habt lasst einfach daumen nach oben da
daumen nach oben oder schreibt sie die
kommentare keine ahnung und ansonsten
haben wir uns überlegt wir machen jetzt
schon mal gemacht aber halt noch nicht
mit ihm
dieses wäre würde er weil es ist
eigentlich mega lustig und zwar ich
erkläre es jetzt auch noch weil er weiß
auch noch nicht
für die die es nicht kennen wir haben
jeweils beide hier so ein zettel auf
einem steht einmal sein name auf einem
steht mein name ich hoffe da kann man
lesen und dann kommen also frage ich
hatte euch auf dienstag um gefragt ja
stellt mal fragen
diese werde erst zum beispiel wäre würde
er aus dem fenster springen lassen jetzt
mal ganz grob und wenn er denkt ich
würde er aus dem fenster springen hält
er meint wenn ich denke er würde aus dem
fenster springt hält er meinen zettel
heutig seinen 200
checkt das müssen wir auf jeden fall
viel spaß die bio und ja sagen
viel spaß so leute was auf erste frage
und zwar wer würde er bei einer
schlechten note die unterschrift der
eltern fälschen echt ok ich muss es
eigentlich gar nicht mehr weil ich muss
meine leistung war okay
ja okay dann wärs schon du weißt du
hörst das dann machen obwohl ich
brauchst ja nicht mehr
ok tut mir leid aber du machst du was ja
nicht nur wer würde er auf insulin
verzichten
ja gut ich kann nicht sagen falls ihm
geht ja ich ne außerdem euch mehr
vorbereitung ist das schon mal ein grund
so nächste frage wer würde sich eher
zwei wochen lang nur von mcdonald's
ernähren ich glaube ganz gleich und ich
glaube ich tue es auch schon so fasst
ein spaß aber ich bin sehr oft irgendwo
da so etwas das fast food thema angeht
und ja wir zunächst in diesen minuten
wer würde er einen löffel salz essen
ich glaube ich brauche ich ein auto
formieren
pass auf ich hab ja vorgesorgt
schön bitter es ist schon mal versucht
noch nicht immer aber ich es immer so
sein bzw männer ist drauf ein ganzer
dafür kaufen
ich würde mal sagen bisher noch nie so
probieren zwischendecke nicht ob mein
handy traum aber wenn sich geht dann
gern verkaufen
ich weiß nicht wie sicher bitter bitter
bitter
seit wann ist ein salzgitter hallo sagen
ja sagt sauer salzig ja echt schlecht
wer würde er von zu hause ausziehen
das ist auch eine frage sehr oft
gestellten das auch gelesen ich würde
mal sagen
links ist ja ich bin auch bald 18 und
fertig mit schule was heißt bald
eineinhalb jahre ungefähr einem jahr
noch bisschen mehr
und dann habe ich keine ahnung aber ich
dass das ergibt sogar sehen werde er
ausziehen ich ziehe denke ich mal heraus
wer würde er zum supertalent gehen
aber ich wüsste ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
was da zeigen sollte wer würde er mich
mit eistee trinken
mach ich bin ich bin jetzt mal fair und
hält deswegen mit locken aber damit
ausprobieren
es geht wohl schmeckt gar nicht mal so
schlecht wird sommer probieren was merkt
eigentlich glaube ich denke jetzt öfter
management system also nächste frage und
ist sogar die letzte wer würde er ins
dschungelcamp gehen haltung mal zuerst
hoch verschuldeten ich gucke auch nicht
hin
also ich glaub du würdest er kaka
ladenflächen warum kein okay aber die
also ich würde direkt ins studium gehen
nominiert mich daran gehe ich dahin kein
problem ja gut leute das war's mit dem
video wir hoffen natürlich jetzt habe
ich gefallen hier kommt ihr zu seinem
instagram könnte ja mal vorbei schauen
hier ist meins eingeblendet und
ansonsten würde ich sagen ich habe sie
eben schon erwähnt also wie hamburg
zusammen kanals machen eventuell
schreibt in die kommentare oder so und
ja schon zu sehen wir uns schon im laufe
der nächsten woche da kommt video
ansonsten eher geht es hier auf der
linken seite weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war hier so 30 facts about me
und hier auf der anderen seite kommt ihr
zu einem video von uns beiden das erste
video von uns beiden aber nicht
vergessen wir nichts mehr verpassen
wollte und will noch immer sagen
bis zum nächsten mal